hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to don't starve
remember how we said we weren't gonna uh
we're gonna be right back where we were
well we tried it didn't work we died a
lot it was bad
so here's ya Bob yeah it's good now I
don't know why you're hedging it once
it's gone so well yeah everything it's
all it's this is perfectly the plan yeah
so you might be getting my head yeah
yeah yeah yeah you might be confused as
to where we are so let me show you a
short few minute montage of our getting
to this point including what happened
when we try to get our stuff back
how about four-wheeler thank you we're
very close okay
is it time good for a basic maneuvers of
[ __ ] hell yeah it's really just the
Hornets here they come
I have you on me yeah cut through this
way okay go around back off ah okay Oh
woo get one guy oh oh geez oh [ __ ] oh
jeez there's so many I'm the only [ __ ]
you're dead again oh boy oh my god my
soul ghost is here getting the [ __ ]
stung out of her by a Hornet oh Jesus
oh there's so many oh this was a
horrible error why are we here well I
think we're [ __ ]
hi friend hello I think there might be
Beefalo that's like a bee flew area
north-northwest right oh hey Wuerffel
let's jump in all this didn't go
anywhere far away this is stupid world
wait this is a desert this is not where
we want to be I don't think I don't
think we should be here oh there's no
Beefalo anywhere this is a dead end also
what if at the end of the desert it's
like an oasis of Beefalo ants a dead end
and please be a dead end [ __ ] all is it
dead end too good god I am the worst why
why is this like this I don't know
there's your baby
damn beats probably another dead end
over there
well this look looks dead end ish oh
it's so dead oh jeez oh jeez oh jeez oh
jeez
this is just a big Peninsula god damn
really gonna turn into a dead end it's a
dead end it's dead and it's dead god
dammit the [ __ ] wasn't that fun okay
alright
hey look it's day thank ya okay so we
were in this wormhole let's go in this
wormhole indeed okay so if you are
curious as to what we're doing in this
episode it's interesting we were trying
to find some B flow and we lit up when
literally everywhere not literally
everywhere we went a lot of where's and
we just couldn't find B below so oh well
we did find was something that we've
never seen before ever and we have no
idea what it is so we're gonna try to
fight it super cool yeah so we were
around here in this like lava area oh
it's moving oh my oh it's moving hello
howdy okay I am here to barter with you
oh my god it's coming from Asus oh my
god it does not like you oh my god
you're damn how are you doing
doesn't want to dammit oh oh I get it I
get it
it's gone dragonfly oh my god okay call
it's caught it's a it's called a dragon
the dragonfly
it's called a dragonfly alright so
there's a cool thing uh that we're gonna
show you it's called
starting another world and changing
what's this gay man oh man we got to do
it we got to do it we got to do it man
we got to do it I'm gonna start new sir
we're gonna have Beefalo right there
I will not smudge Mike's okay Rob right
if if if there aren't if there aren't
if there aren't i'm ragequitting and
never playing this game again I uh okay
no pressure mark oh it's doing good are
you gonna adjust the settings so that we
spawn into a utopia like that one time I
don't have any settings like that now oh
yes I do
everything everywhere so that it's so
crowded you can't even put anything down
[ __ ] it
but I'm not gonna do that because I tell
you I tell you I can't tell you there's
gonna be be flow I'm generating the
world right now you're gonna see man
you're gonna see okay
be flow everywhere like they're [ __ ]
in every corner of this world they're
making more Beefalo babies it's just be
flow out the ass everywhere you look oh
my god it's like too many people Oh mmm
it's so many B flow that you can't even
kill a B flow because the other B flow
will kill you
mm-hmm no I'm coming that's what it's
gonna be like tap then trust me it's
gonna be awesome
Rost me dude trust me dude
I do died it's me trusting you let me do
D trust I'm Russian I'm all the way in
right now all right I just be born to
trust look it's a field it's a field
yeah yeah that's a start yeah art oh
yeah dude when I promise I deliver and
when I deliver okay just remember what
the deal was if there are no Beefalo
right near spawn oh jeez it's clockwork
ah that's good but okay it it may not
seem like B flow right now but just give
it a no I'm still I'm still with you the
north west this way yeah slightly not
and uh navigated it means a lot that
your faith in me is well-placed full
full faith yes please and Croquet you
can do this okay um I see there's an it
look it's another it's another it all
the other field Bob that's the one
that's the Hollis [ __ ] horny toad
what the hell is [ __ ] happening
[ __ ] toad alright forget that ouch
oh not you toad not like this ow
they really hurt okay I'm not gonna do
that they steal your stuff too okay this
is not a big there was uh okay oh uh oh
[ __ ] it's more clockwork stuff what is
going on okay well hang on we know what
I'm not getting up yet I still have
faith in you all right cool this is a
dead end
whoa um they could be in a rocky area
right don't don't give up men don't they
could be in a rocky area I'm pretty sure
maybe they change people Oh habitats
yeah I've heard rumors that you could
have Beefalo in a major species it's
it's rock Beefalo Rock Lee rockello
maybe they took the flow out of the game
why did we need people Oh anyway it's
your unhealthy obsession with Beefalo
that caused us to do this you need
people Oh poop to make things like farms
or cooking's that's true things what
about our poop can we use that well we
got to do something this can't be an
episode without something you ah I think
I'm just gonna cut it off when you
finally give up on the notion of finding
people know this [ __ ] Beefalo out
there ah goddamn it I'm sure there are
somewhere dis Miller that we've ever
looked yet yes that's true so we need to
give this is another dead end
good god this is nothing but dead ends
that's [ __ ] why why were you going
straight south I don't know where I'm
going now I'm just going everywhere
there's gotta be I'm gonna find him for
you I'm gonna find him for you
and you're finally gonna respect me I
respect you maybe finally gonna respect
you you're finally gonna respect me as a
human being I have plenty of respect for
you as a human being I I sense the air
quotes when you said respect I said it
like that but I didn't actually do air
quotes
okay but no I have lots of respect for
you okay hey I found Beefalo just lying
you're lying to me I am lying there are
nine hello is the one time I finally
learned not to trust your lies Wow after
all this time when I say I found Beefalo
in a completely meaningless round of
don't start together that's when you
decide it's time to start challenging
the truths I tell it's not meaningless
it's it's a little bit meaningless as we
can't find before we can be flow isn't
everything but we can't wait wait I
found a grass biome okay uh-huh uh-huh
uh-huh
it's not it hasn't ended yet uh-huh all
righty then do these dead all
suppressive
I mean impressive is the wrong word it's
almost okay enough to make me question
whether this is worth it okay let me
make one more game why it's just you
just make me hooked up one more come on
just one more if you've got five four
minutes left
you've got four minutes left I will only
allow this if you if you make a if you
sing a whole new world while it's
loading in okay I can do that I'll go do
its part as much as far as I know I
don't really know what that well right
okay yeah I gotta make this and everyone
can see I'm not doing this like I'm not
upgrading the things okay all right all
right check out for edits there might be
some edits there's no edits this is
completely uncut watch out for including
the singing all right get it I can show
you the world I have to sing it happy
can't sing at me angrily I can show you
the world shining bliss that's not the
right phrase there something tent and
antenna on a magic carpet ride Oh
oh no you have to sing his part what I
really don't know that song no Jasmine
comes and goes a whole new world and
then you go don't you dare close don't
you dare close your eyes if the game's
loaded so far good get it
are you really you really [ __ ]
offensive be full I would be blown oh is
it
there's a dead body with some boards by
us is that before
that's not Beefalo it's it's boards okay
it's closed there I swear this one's
gonna have Beefalo alright you go north
or south I went north the kind of north
west dish I'm gonna go south we're gonna
let's do this let's do this from all
angles okay all right
and don't go like oh people oh and you
know until there's actually be fooled
South is a dead end
okay there's a grass I already did that
oh I found Beefalo wow it's a complete
dead end like two seconds from our spawn
wow you see brillier a bush what where
am I supposed to go that's a dead end
south and straight West from our spots
I found a juicy berry bush I don't know
what that is it's just like a really
really quality berry bush apparently oh
I found it an I bone I can get Chester
oh nice Chester he'll be useful yeah
okay that's helpful it's not beef oh
there he is
there's Chester I just ER what's this
game called just find a Beefalo for
[ __ ] sake
that's funny mood don't don't forget to
not find a Beefalo seriously we started
on a [ __ ] closed off Peninsula are
you [ __ ] me
less to south and east are all complete
dead ends you have to go north for like
a long time to get out of here Oh No
what's a Mandrake is that thing gonna
knock me out oh oh wow oh my god does
Mandrake that was really sad what
happened I don't know it just it popped
out of the ground in a game for like a
pathetic little cry and then it died Wow
jeez oh my god why is there so many you
[ __ ] horny toad Uche bags
what is a hey it's a juicy dirty bush
yeah that's what I found we [ __ ] you
frog I know right
hugs are douches so how's the Beefalo
hunt coming
[Music]
I found it I found it Far East follow
the road East if you go north a little
bit out of that Peninsula and then
follow the road all the waste oh I've
found yes okay you won't believe me
until you get here I won't believe me
until you get here you got to go north
from spawn go around that little crevice
and then he'll them East till you find a
road it's kind of like a South Eastern
Road mm-hmm and it may just no there's
more than that oh there's a lot of
people over here I'm gonna chop wood
we're gonna make camp oh he's gonna be
so good oh it's gonna be so good evening
now so I hope it's not too far away
no it's you'll make it oh my god that's
don't don't do that
there's just three there's three people
is looking at me wait where I'm on the
I'm on a road that's going sort of
northeast northeast oh I think I'm south
east of you okay you went way further
north than I did yeah I am south east of
you currently in the same grasslands
because there's a northwesterly road
okay I'm coming to that grassland if on
the on the western border of that
grasslands you see a forest with pine
trees right I can't see the western
border but at the southern border where
I entered there was a forest with pine
trees okay I'm coming back wait a minute
oh no you're in a different you're in a
different one oh well okay we many
Beefalo yeah we found many Beefalo okay
but this is good right Oh is how is this
good I don't know oh I don't know okay
like on my map if you look at the
diamond hashes my guy is exactly four
and a half dashes to the right and then
one half like diamond south of
the spiral star spawn point that's where
my guy is [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] that dance oh
it's yeah yeah it's nighttime [ __ ] do
you not have I have a torch okay battle
hell here's the spiral spawn what are
you talking about
okay if you look on the map south of the
spawn that's where you are that's where
I am I'm way the [ __ ] far north with you
I'm straight north of you like 10 or 15
diamonds what wait how zoomed out how
zoomed out are you where I forgot this
could zoom in and out oh jesus lord
changes the entire dynamic of a yemeni
Primus damn it
well I'm certainly way further north and
you're describing okay I am I am almost
straight north I'm like North barely
north east of the spawn and I walked
that's the only direction that I walked
okay so I'm like a lot that direction so
head back towards spawn or all how did
we get separated
you should go north and you have an axe
already right yeah she knows one collect
resources on the way all I have is like
grass okay I'm coming and I will start
collecting Beefalo poops and try and
start trapping rabbits and and doing
that sort of stuff okay
this is a plan and then once we get
together then we'll be golden we can
stop the episode and everything will be
cool that'll be the conclusion our
reuniting yeah we won't it wait that'll
be good okay so you're directly north of
the spawn I'm directly north of it
basically so did you have to cross a
pine forest to get to that grassland I
think so and is there a stone road that
you had to go through yes I used a stone
road that went sort of northeast oh and
it's really zig zaggy yes okay
okay I'm on the right path yes it's
super zigzag oh I see below where are
you I am uh oh [ __ ] I might be isolated
right now I went north exploring and
nope okay I'm connected damn not seeing
you but I need to get more wood
are you in the grassland right now oh
yeah I'm just at the swamp edge of it I
should have gotten my right trees on the
way up
did you follow the road over there yeah
I'm following the road back down to get
some trees cuz there's no you I didn't
realize there were no trees up I'm on
the road
oh no I'm at the swamp edge of it [ __ ]
okay so you're right near me but I'm
just going into the pine forest and
getting some trees this reunite a ssin
is gonna be so epic it's gonna be like
orgasmic alright I'm back down in the
pine forest area no I'm not I'm here
you're coming to me I was gonna come to
you when I'm done getting wood wow that
sounds like your own private personal
business but okay I got I got a good bit
of wood get me back up at the grassland
yeah we did I play this game we did it
oh I missed you so much
I don't have any grass ah
we need grass work to build a fire hair
oh and then the Bosque yay okay we did
it
oh all right
so now we got Beefalo just like we told
you we would so thank you everybody for
believing in us right Bob okay okay okay
alright so thanks again everybody for
watching and then if you want more of
this we will continue in the Beefalo
force so thank again now as always we'll
see you in next
buh-bye take that nature you tell that
nature it's been mean to you anyway why
is there ceiling on the blood how the
hell did so much blood getting on the
roof how is a excellent question